this is a sad moment for me as someone
who cares deeply about the violence of
Chicago I felt a glimmer of hope last
year when I interviewed a young man by
the name of little Greg Gregory a
Jennings was a young man whom I offered
a proposal to that if I helped him get a
job he would get out of the life of
crime violence drugs and gangbanging he
accepted if somebody were to give you a
job would you get out of her life
I got jobs and opportunities for your
resources so if you get a job if I help
you get a job you would get out of the
life you would no longer be involved in
the gangs a hundred percent on live
national television saying she would get
out the gang if you had that opportunity
I stayed in touch with them via calls
and text messages and then I couldn't
reach him anymore then I found out via
media reported the little Greg was
gunned down right here behind me two men
walked up and shot him in cold blood at
4:30 in the afternoon little Greg is
lost but he's never forgotten
that was Fox contributor in Chicago
native Giano caldwell bringing us a
tragic update on a young man that we
featured as you could see on last year's
town hall it's just another example of
just how hard it can be to escape the
cycle of violence once you're in it here
in Chicago
without strong male leadership it's so
critical in their lives young men in the
inner city are increasingly susceptible
to being pulled into the gang life one
Mirchi meant one man here with us
tonight has made it his mission to help
young people create a better future for
themselves here now with me is dr. Devin
Horton former principal of Phillips
Academy high school and joining him are
two success stories Brandon Lane a
Phillips Academy graduate who has gang
members in his family and Cedric
Willingham former mentee of dr. Horton
and a victim himself of gun violence dr.
Horton you saw that young man from our
package last year almost pleading for an
opportunity to leave the gang life and
one year later he's dead how do we solve
this it's a it's a multiple there
support approach that we have to in
order in order to reach these young man
and I'm speaking to speak really from
the educational lands and I've really
failed that in working here in Chicago
for 14 years prior to me leaving six
years ago there was a we there's there's
a we have to give the students a sense
of hope and it's not about reading and
math as much as it's about giving them
how to survive and life in general so
something that we're currently doing on
my current district why I serve as chief
of schools in Louisville Kentucky
we actually have career education
programs where they have them here but
what's really unique about what's
happening there students are actually
getting trained and for UPS work for
General Electric work and they actually
have an opportunity to get the
certifications required
so go into the field didn't have
opportunity so these are life skills
these are skills to get to get out and
actually work yes or get a job just well
you can make friend of Mines a FedEx
driver
thanks a lot of money like 10 year big
money but you know be there on time sure
Tucker shirt and look at someone I mean
these are common sense but not to
everyone yeah we all have to learn them
yes and I think from the education side
we understand we touched these students
every day so more than a police more
than any other community organizations
we have them in our we have them in our
buildings and we have to find a way to
collectively wrap our hands around as a
group and as a team so to support them
hope and knowing that someone cares
about what happens to you in the next 24
hours I want you back in school the next
day
cédric in 2016 you were shot 13 times
outside of a hospital it was a random
attack you say this moment completely
changed your outlook in life obviously
you're in a wheelchair as a result of
this what is your message to young kids
toying with the idea of joining a
joining a gang it ain't it ain't fun
ain't as fun as it's cracked up to be or
you think it is don't get you far you
either gonna get something gonna happen
to you or you're gonna be locked up it's
about it so I'm just try to keep the
head up keep they trust in a self don't
trust nobody else don't believe what
other people say believe what you see
and what you know what I tell them
Brandon members of your family have
themselves gotten completely sucked into
the gang life you avoided it there is a
cycle and families of their cycle a lot
of things alcoholism touches all
families drug abuse which is also part
of this problem which we're gonna get
into you manage pull yourself out of
that you had a mentor Cedric you also
ended up having a mentor and dr. Horta
how did you do it though I'm so just
like you said out of a mentor dr. Gordon
and I also have other mentors John Byrne
Corey Lee just those guys really
believing in me I said given he's got to
give him guys hope um he was a principal
but he also was a father figure a
brother and a friend he actually
contacted me every day while I was in I
graduated what two years ago with my
bachelor's degree pursuing my master's
degree now he still contacted me to this
day so basically you know not just
talking taking
actually you know helping these kids and
not just tell them oh I believe in you
show them that you believe in them and
give them something to believe in
yourself know how important our male
role models dr. Horton especially in
situations where young men are in
fatherless homes mom's trying to do
their very best I'm a single mother but
I have resources a lot of moms don't how
hard is a fatherless situation for any
person from any background so what I
would say this I'm actually was raised
by a single mother and Robert sealed
housing projects in the whole and that's
what that's what it was called but I
would say oftentimes our our our young
men are over mother and under father and
so because of our work and it's so
important to drive I talked to Brandon
all the time and even cetera about how
do we give back and getting back into
the classroom and being educators
because that's a direct pipeline to
these young men it's so many young men
that I've had interactions with over my
20-year career like it is it is
imperative there's a certain things that
moms will call me and say mr. Horton
Devon can you talk to Brandon about XYZ
or whatever it may be and I'm able to do
have certain conversations the mothers
they try they do a great job but it's
tough I have that problem with my two
boys and I again I have resources I mean
eternally blessed but I have to bring in
male role models father figures
Godfather's Cedric how important this is
very important cuz you gotta you gotta
have the right man to know what type of
man that you could be if you only got
that role models in that's just gonna be
one of those things that either you just
get lost in trying to find out yourself
which is real hard without a father or I
don't know what I don't know other way
which other way you could become a man
what actually seeing becoming a man what
it what it means to become a man's real
man though as a real man thank you